thank you hey everyone my name is
Alejandra
and this talk will be about JavaScript
engines you'll find that through all the
documentation and references
they are also referenced Bertil machine
so this could be considered as an
introduction to a subtype of virtual
machines but before we continue I wanted
to say three things about this talk
first the first one is why I care about
these things at some point I became
obsessed with performance and speed but
it's something I think we all can relate
to which for the fastest card the
fastest swimmer the fastest runner and
in programming we look for faster
applications of faster algorithms faster
functions run faster micro operations I
realized that to answer some of these
questions I needed to understand these
things the second thing I wanted to tell
you is why I think you should care about
this talk I believe that having some
understanding on this subject will give
you the tools to think and reason about
what makes your code fast or slow and as
you are deeper into the more complex
details you will gain insight in all the
ranges between those two extremes the
third one on last is a really big
disclaimer I'm fascinated by virtual
machines and compilers but I'm not a
virtual machine specialist and certainly
do not represent any of the browser
vendors mentioned here if you find
something that's wrong or could be faced
in a better way please reach out to me
so I started my path going through that
by the way that's me
if you can recognize me it's probably
the hurt
it's okay I started my path going
through the history of JavaScript
engines and he found an inflection point
around 2006 2007 before that time
engines were pretty straightforward they
the engine would to the source code and
parse it to an abstract syntax tree or
ASD for sure and I ast will meet
comments parentheses commas semicolons
all the things that are part of the
syntax and will represent block blocks
and statements as nodes in a tree
structure the next step would be to
transform the ast to byte code which is
an internal representation by code can
be described as a well-defined set of
instructions and can be also considered
as a portable representation
since divide code instructions will not
change through the different CPU
architectures machine code on the other
hand will change its architecture
specific meaning that for the same lines
of JavaScript it's machine code will
vary from a model CPU to desktop or
laptop CPUs the final step needed for
the running for running your program is
what I call an execution phase which is
often described as really big switch
statement that for each byte
construction will graph and will jump to
the appropriate code like in most
high-level languages JavaScript will not
deal with memory locations explicitly
you can create objects on all those
objects will be allocated internally by
the engine those objects can also be in
reference and in order to reuse those
precious bits of memory the system will
need a garbage collector there are
different strategies to implement
garbage collectors but we will leave
those details for later turns out this
set up this architecture is considerably
is conservatively slow were slow means
implicitly comparing to the performance
of C or C++ program after all the
optimizations are applied so a good a
group of brilliant people worked on
improvements over this architecture in
the 70s for Fortran in the 80s for us
and solve runtimes and they came up with
this concept of adaptive optimization
with the idea the idea is to identify
the pieces of your program that are
executing too often are also called hot
functions and to compile them on run
time hence the name just-in-time
compiler or [ __ ] compiler for short
after compilation the ancient wouldn't
have any other head for running the code
well with just the interpreter that will
have to go through the the really big
switch from bytecode instructions to the
code each time you are executing that
this approach it's also a great
opportunity to apply the optimistic
optimizations in diagramming languages
like JavaScript for example collecting
type information about the context of a
function called could open the
possibilities for type specializing
optimizations in order to optimize
property access in the enemy languages
during caches or ICS for short were
invented in caches our way to save a
fast path the first time in access the
property it will use a slow path but
will recall all the steps needed to get
it global variables variables from
closures and even prototype chains can
be optimized by ICS imagine that after
optimization a hundred objects length
prototype chain could he'll have almost
the same performance that accessing a
property of an object with no prototype
at all and that's amazing that's the
performance improvement you could get by
just using inline caches the basis for
most ancient implementations consists of
interpreter and to optimizing compilers
on your left the one that optimized
compilation time and on your right the
one that optimized execution time the
one optimizing execution time also
called optimizing compiler
will highly depend on the type
information collected from the system
the on obtain an optimizing compiler
would generally create England caches
and help Colette type information type
changes in the code could trigger type
the type specializing compiler to
recompile and in some cases after an
excessive amount of time changes the the
compiler could desist and penalize the
code marking it as non optimizable
switching to a real-world architecture
SpiderMonkey is not too far from the
previous example it will receive the
source code I will transfer me to a
bytecode after the number of times a
function is executed goes over a certain
threshold it will then be marked as
optimisation by the first compiler which
is baseline after the number of times a
function is executed goes goes over a
second threshold it will then be marked
as candidate for really really good
optimization that's when IO monkey kicks
in and with the byte code plus the type
information collected it will compile
the function with all the optimizations
that kind of like the previous example
where both compilers would bail out to
the interpreter in this case the code
will bail out to the baseline sheet in
the case of track record it shows a
similar architecture to spider monkey
and it has an interpreter and optimizing
an optimizing compiler which is a simple
cheat and an optimizing compiler
photoshoot
the interesting part about chat rocker
is that he can fire
additional threats to compile or to run
the garbage collection
imagine that you're running the engine
on a fork or CPU in theory you could
take advantage of that and compile
paralyze the ship compilation in three
of those core
in the case of BA it has recently
switched to afford to the architecture
it has an interpreter it has an an
optimizing compiler also called full
culture and to optimizing compilers hang
shot on turbofan the full cogent
compiler resembles to the baseline sheet
of SpiderMonkey both will create inline
caches if b8 profilers in the identifies
that a function is taking a good
proportion of the execution time it will
then notify the the system to optimize
it both crankshaft and turbofan applies
optimistic optimizations and type
specializing optimizations there are dia
is to deprecated eventually crankshaft
and full Cochin and just leave munition
and the the turbofan compiler
javascriptcore has also a four tiered
architecture has an interpreter and an
optimizing compiler and to optimizing
compilers the FG compiler and FTO
if finest the statement is executed more
than a hundred times or the function is
called more than six times the engine
will then optimize with the baseline
compiler once the statement goes over a
thousand times or the function is calmer
than 66 times the function will be
compiled using DFG once that numbers
goes over 10,000 the FGL compiler kicks
in as you can see there's a component
inside dfdl which is a little be M L o
BM is a compiler that applies all sorts
of optimizations and search as a
back-end for f GL that means the engine
would gather the time in front
information they bytecode and transform
that into lower-level representation to
fit that into a low VM
they also recently switched to to
another back in for the FTL compiler
called v3 but that's only on OSX
machines and they were looking to keep
all the optimizations they wanted but
reduce the compilation time which is
briefly talked about the different
architectures for most advances
JavaScript engines notes let's talk
about the specific optimizations they
are all applying let's say you have a
look
executed many times and its side its
body a single expression of finding the
variable were incremented multiplied by
some arbitrary number the reasonable
performance improvement would be to make
the calculation once I'm reference it
through a temporary variable in all the
iterations all the ancients mentioned
here applies this optimization
internally and it's called loop
invariant code motion one of the
simplest optimizations at JIT compiler
could apply is called functioning
language let's come back to your
canonical and inside its body we execute
a function if the loop iterates a
certain amount of times the profiler
will identify the function as hot and if
some conditions apply
we'll grab the functions body and paste
it directly inside the loop now you may
be wondering why it should be faster
since it's the same code in low-level
programming languages like assembly
calling a function would end up in a
context which recently after the
function call you will have to save the
previous context and right after you
return from the function you'll have to
resume that saved context let's continue
with the the next optimization imagine a
loop with just an expression it could be
an expression you want but if it doesn't
have side effects like assigning the
result to a variable
that's one yeah like assigning the
result variable or returning the result
it could be optimized by just about in
doing anything at all and that's what
the compiler will do internally just
remove the expression this accepting
station is called death called
elimination and some compilers like the
JVM good would go further and lick the
whole loop just be aware that some of
the features of JavaScript will inhibit
type specializing optimizations like the
eval function the width operator and
try-catch blocks we mentioned before
that there's different strategies to
implement garbage collecting systems
here you can see a brief comparison of
all the different implementations
generational garbage collectors will
group objects by their life span and
we'll assume that young objects are more
likely to leave to die sorry that old
objects under these strategy the new
objects are created in a nursery space
and long-lived objects are moved to
channel space incremental G sees inter
leave their work with the activity from
the main program well on the other hand
stop the world strategy will halt the
execution of the main program until a
full collection is done disease can also
be described as precise or conservative
ones precise ones can identify all the
references while conservative ones will
find will look for memory patterns to
find references the slack the last
approach could lead to false positives
but that's not always a problem in
practice
in this following link you can find all
the resources that I use while working
on this presentation if you want to read
more about cheat compilers or garbage
collection and you're interested in to
the details there's a lot of material in
there there's also some questions that I
keep uploading to that to myself and
there's some conversation about it you
can always find me after the talk and
ask me anything you want just to wrap up
a good question about this topic that I
came it was how do you measure the
overall performance of any of those
JavaScript engines and there's not a
really good answer to that there's a lot
of benchmarks out there to test all the
edge case but certainly micro benchmarks
will not show show you the whole picture
that being said I think we all should
strive for maintainable and clean code
all the optimizations techniques that I
came across have reasonable requirements
to apply like functions to be
monomorphic things more related to
dynamic typing and have nothing to do
with using obscure features of language
that's all thank you